what's it like always known the truth  there's nothing Miss Ed call about it I  could just  imagine anyone is lying yeah  I Know What You Did you're psycho  [Music]  you live on the road right listen like  leave everything behind start fresh  I got rolls on my Fender oh I gotta keep  moving  holy holy  it wasn't an accident I think there's  been a murder  foreign  I have been kind of a death magnet  [Music]  I'm trying to figure out what happened  if you watch too much Dateline I could  tell she was lying well it's a woman's  intuition no it's not like a tampon  commercial okay it's a real thing  [Music]  front seat of the trunk  your choice  [Music]  I guess I'm not over the part where  you're a human lie detector yeah I know  it's uh it's crazy you ever gamble  because you can make a killing  me